منذ اليوم الروبل الروسي هو العمله
الوحيده التي سيتم تداولها في المقاطعه
الاوكرانيه التي سبق وانضمتها موسكو اليها
والتوقف عن تداول العمله الاوكرانيه
الهريبنا القرار يشمل المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره روسيا في مقاطعه اقليم ندوم باس
دنيا اسكو ولكن
زبرجيا وخرسون من شان هذا القرار ترسيخ
السياده الروسيه على تلك المقاطعات اذ
ياتي ايضا بعد قرارات اخرى تتعلق بمنح
الجنسيه الروسيه لسكانيه تلك المناطق
واعتماد الاسماء الروسيه لمدنها وبلداتها
بدلا من الاوكرانيا وتغيير رمز الاتصال
الدولي لها على الصعيد الاقتصادي انتظروا
ان يساهم القرار في تخفيف الاثار المتعلقه
بالعقبات الغربيه من خلال توسيع التداول
بالروبلبل ومن شانه ان يؤدي الى تخفيض نسب
التضخم واستقرار قيمه العمله فضلا عن انه
سيسرع من التي دمج النشاط الاقتصادي
والعمليات الماليه في تلك المناطق في بنيه
الاقتصاد الروسي تعود اصول الروبل الروسي
الى القرن 13 حين تم استعماله كلمه روبل
لاول مره في اماره نوفاغورد احدى مدن
الشمال الغربيه لروسيا للدلاله على
السبائك المصنوعه من الفضه
[موسيقى]